And finally we look at the 6
And at that point we are done.
We're going to get started.
Handouts are the by the door
if anybody didn't pick one up.
My name is Charles Leiserson.
I will be lecturing this
course this term, Introduction
to Algorithms,
with Erik Demaine.
In addition, this is an
SMA course, a Singapore MIT
Alliance course which will be
run in Singapore by David Hsu.
And so all the lectures
will be videotaped and made
available on the Web for
the Singapore students,
as well as for MIT students
who choose to watch them
on the Web.
If you have an issue of not
wanting to be on the videotape,
you should sit in the back row.
OK?
Otherwise, you will be on it.
There is a video
recording policy,
but it seems like they ran out.
If anybody wants
to see it, people,
if they could just
sort of pass them
around maybe a little bit,
once you're done reading it,
or you can come up.
I did secure one copy.
Before we get into the
content of the course,
let's briefly go over
the course information
because there are some
administrative things that we
sort of have to do.
As you can see, this
term we have a big staff.
Take a look at the handout here.
Including this
term six TAs, which
is two more TAs than we
normally get for this course.
That means recitations
will be particularly small.
There is a World Wide Web page,
and you should bookmark that
and go there regularly
because that is where
everything will be distributed.
Email.
You should not be
emailing directly to,
even though we give you
our email addresses,
to the individual
members of the staff.
You should email us generally.
And the reason is you will
get much faster response.
And also, for any
communications,
generally we like to monitor
what the communications are
so it's helpful to have
emails coming to everybody
on the course staff.
As I mentioned, we will be doing
distance learning this term.
And so you can watch
lectures online
if you choose to do that.
I would recommend, for people
who have the opportunity
to watch, to come live.
It's better live.
You get to interact.
There's an intangible that
comes with having it live.
In fact, in addition
to the videos,
I meet weekly with
the Singapore students
so that they have a
live session as well.
Prerequisites.
The prerequisites
for this course
are 6.042, which is Math for
Computer Science, and 6.001.
You basically need discrete
mathematics and probability,
as well as
programming experience
to take this course
successfully.
People do not have that
background should not
be in the class.
We will be checking
prerequisites.
If you have any
questions, please
come to talk to us after class.
Let's see.
Lectures are here.
For SMA students, they
have the videotapes
and they will also
have a weekly meeting.
Students must attend a one hour
recitation session each week.
There will be new material
presented in the recitation.
Unlike the lectures,
they will not be online.
there will not
be lecture notes distributed
for the recitations in general.
And, yet, there will
be material there
that is directly on the exams.
And so every term we say
oh, when did you cover that?
That was in recitation.
You missed that one.
So, recitations are mandatory.
And, in particular,
also let me just
mention your recitation
instructor is the one who
assigns your final grade.
So we have a grade meeting
and keep everybody normal,
but your recitation has the
final say on your grade.
Handouts.
Handouts are available
on the course Web page.
We will not generally, except
for this one, first handout,
be bringing handouts to class.
Textbook is this book,
Introduction to Algorithms.
MIT students can get it any of
the local bookstores, including
the MIT Coop.
There is also a
new online service
that provides textbooks.
You can also get a
discount if you buy it
at the MIT Press Bookstore.
There is a coupon in the MIT
Student Telephone Directory
for a discount on
MIT Press books.
And you can use that to purchase
this book at a discount.
Course website.
This is the course website.
It links to the
Stellar website, which
is where, actually,
everything will be kept.
And SMA students have
their own website.
Some students find this
course particularly challenges
so we will have extra help.
We will post weekly
office hours on the course
website for the TAs.
And then as an
experiment this term,
we are going to offer
homework labs for this class.
What a homework lab is,
is it's a place and a time
you can go where other
people in the course
will go to do homework.
And there will be typically
two TAs who staff the lab.
And so, as you're
working on your homework,
you can get help from
the TAs if you need it.
And it's generally a place,
we're going to schedule those,
and they will be on the course
calendar for where it is
and when it is that they
will be held, but usually
Sundays 2:00 to 4:00 pm, or
else it will be some evening.
I think the first one
is an evening, right?
Near to when the
homework is due.
Your best bet is try
to do the homework
in advance of the homework lab.
But then, if you
want extra help,
if you want to talk over
your solutions with people
because as we will
talk about problem sets
you can solve in collaboration
with other people in the class.
In addition, there are several
peer assistance programs.
Also the office of
Minority Education
has an assistance
program, and those usually
get booked up pretty quickly.
If you're interested
in those, good idea
to make an appointment to
get there and get help soon.
The homework labs, I hope a lot
of people will try that out.
We've never done this.
I don't know of
any other course.
Do other people know of courses
at MIT that have done this?
6.011 did it, OK.
Good.
And was it successful
in that class?
It never went,
OK.
Good. [LAUGHTER] We will see.
If it's not paying
off then we will just
return to ordinary office
hours for those TAs,
but I think for some students
that is a good opportunity.
If you wish to be
registered in this course,
you must sign up on
the course Web page.
So, that is requirement one.
It must be done today.
You will find it difficult to
pass the course if you are not
in the class.
And you should
notify your TA if you
decide to drop so that
we can get you off
and stop the mailings,
stop the spam.
And you should register
today before 7:00 PM.
And then we're going to email
your recitation assignment
to you before Noon tomorrow.
And if you don't receive this
information by Thursday Noon,
please send us an email
to the course staff
generally, not to
me individually,
saying that you didn't receive
your recitation assignment.
And so if you haven't
received it by Thursday Noon
you want to.
I think generally they
are going to send them
out tonight or at least
by tomorrow morning.
Yeah.
OK.
SMA students don't have
to worry about this.
Problem sets.
We have nine problem sets
that we project will be
assigned during the semester.
A couple things
about problem sets.
Homeworks won't
generally be accepted,
if you have extenuating
circumstances you
should make prior arrangements
with your recitation
instructor.
In fact, almost all of
the administrative stuff,
you shouldn't come
to me to ask and say
can I hand in something late?
You should be talking to
your recitation instructor.
You can read the other
things about the form,
but let me just mention that
there are exercises that
should be solved but not handed
in as well to give you drill
on the material.
I highly recommend you
doing the exercises.
They both test your
understanding of the material,
and exercises have this way of
finding themselves on quizzes.
You're often asked to
describe algorithms.
And here is a little
outline of what you can
use to describe an algorithm.
The grading policy is
something that somehow I cover.
And always every term
there are at least
a couple of students who pretend
like I never showed them this.
If you skip problems it has a
nonlinear effect on your grade.
Nonlinear, OK?
If you don't skip any problems,
no effect on your grade.
If you skip one problem, a
hundredth of a letter grade,
we can handle that.
But two problems it's a tenth.
And, as you see, by the time you
have skipped like five letter
grades, it is already
five problems.
This is not problem
sets, by the way.
This is problems, OK?
You're down a third
of a letter grade.
And if you don't
do nine or more,
so that's typically about
three to four problem sets,
you don't pass the class.
I always have some students
coming at the end of the year
saying oh, I didn't
do any of my problems.
Can you just pass me because
I did OK on the exams?
Answer no, a very simple answer
because we've said it upfront.
So, the problem sets are an
integral part of the course.
Collaboration policy.
This is extremely important
so everybody pay attention.
If you are asleep now wake up.
Like that's going to
wake anybody up, right?
[LAUGHTER] The goal of homework.
Professor Demaine
and my philosophy
is that the goal of homework is
to help you learn the material.
And one way of helping
to learn is not
to just be stuck and
unable to solve something
because then you're
in no better shape
when the exam roles around,
which is where we're actually
evaluating you.
So, you're encouraged
to collaborate.
But there are some commonsense
things about collaboration.
If you go and you
collaborate to the extent
that all you're doing is getting
the information from somebody
else, you're not
learning the material
and you're not going to
do well on the exams.
In our experience, students
who collaborate generally
do better than students
who work alone.
But you owe it to
yourself, if you're
going to work in a study group,
to be prepared for your study
group meeting.
And specifically you
should spend a half an hour
to 45 minutes on each
problem before you
go to group so
you're up to speed
and you've tried out your ideas.
And you may have
solutions to some,
you may be stuck
on some other ones,
but at least you
applied yourself to it.
After 30 to 45 minutes, if
you cannot get the problem,
just sitting there and banging
your head against it makes no
sense.
It's not a productive
use of your time.
And I know most of you have
issues with having time
on your hands, right?
Like it's not there.
So, don't go banging your
head against problems
that are too hard or
where you don't understand
what's going on or whatever.
That's when the study
group can help out.
And, as I mentioned,
we'll have homework labs
which will give
you an opportunity
to go and do that and
coordinate with other students
rather than necessarily
having to form your own group.
And the TAs will be there.
If your group is unable
to solve the problem then
talk to other groups or ask
your recitation instruction.
And, that's how you
go about solving them.
Writing up the
problem sets, however,
is your individual
responsibility
and should be done alone.
You don't write up your problem
solutions with other students,
you write them up on your own.
And you should on
your problem sets,
because this is
an academic place,
we understand that the source
of academic information
is very important, if you
collaborated on solutions
you should write a list
of the collaborators.
Say I worked with so
and so on this solution.
It does not affect your grade.
It's just a question
of being scholarly.
It is a violation of this policy
to submit a problem solution
that you cannot orally explain
to a member of the course
staff.
You say oh, well, my write up is
similar to that other person's.
I didn't copy them.
We may ask you to orally
explain your solution.
If you are unable,
according to this policy,
the presumption is
that you cheated.
So, do not write up stuff
that you don't understand.
You should be able to write up
the stuff that you understand.
Understand why you're putting
down what you're putting down.
If it isn't obvious, no
collaboration whatsoever
is permitted on exams.
Exams is when we evaluate you.
And now we're not interested
in evaluating other people,
we're interested
in evaluating you.
So, no collaboration on exams.
We will have a take home
exam for the second quiz.
You should look at the schedule.
If there are problems
with the schedule of that,
we want to know early.
And we will give
you more details
about the collaboration in the
lecture on Monday, November
28th.
Now, generally, the lectures
here, they're mandatory
and you have to know them, but
I know that some people say gee,
9:30 is kind of
early, especially
on a Monday or whatever.
It can be kind of
early to get up.
However, on Monday,
November 28th,
you fail the exam if you do
not show up to lecture on time.
That one day you must show up.
Any questions about that?
That one day you
must show up here,
even if you've been
watching them on the Web.
And generally, if you think
you have transgressed,
the best is to come to
us to talk about it.
We can usually
work something out.
It's when we find somebody has
transgressed from a third party
or from obvious analyses
that we do with homeworks,
that's when things get messy.
So, if you think, for
some reason or other,
oh, I may have done
something wrong,
please come and talk to us.
We actually were students once,
too, albeit many years ago.
Any questions?
So, this class has
great material.
Fabulous material.
And it's really fun, but
you do have to work hard.
Let's talk content.
This is the topic of the
first part of the course.
The first part of the course
is focused on analysis.
The second part of the
course is focused on design.
Before you can do
design, you have
to master a bunch of techniques
for analyzing algorithms.
And then you'll be in a
position to design algorithms
that you can analyze and
that which are efficient.
The analysis of algorithm is
the theoretical study -- --
of computer program performance
-- -- and resource usage.
And a particular
focus on performance.
We're studying how
to make things fast.
In particular,
computer programs.
We also will discover and
talk about other resources
such as communication, such
as memory, whether RAM memory
or disk memory.
There are other resources
that we may care about,
but predominantly we
focus on performance.
Because this is a course
about performance,
I like to put things in
perspective a little bit
by starting out and asking,
in programming, what is more
important than performance?
If you're in an engineering
situation and writing code,
writing software, what's more
important than performance?
Correctness.
Good.
OK.
What else?
Simplicity can be.
Very good.
Yeah.
Maintainability often much more
important than performance.
Cost.
And what type of cost
are you thinking?
No, I mean cost of what?
We're talking
software here, right?
What type of cost
do you have in mind?
There are some costs that
are involved when programming
like programmer time.
So, programmer time is another
thing also that might be.
Stability.
Robustness of the software.
Does it break all the time?
What else?
Come on.
We've got a bunch
of engineers here.
A lot of things.
How about features?
Features can be more important.
Having a wider collection of
features than your competitors.
Functionality.
Modularity.
Is it designed in a way
where you can make changes
in a local part of the code and
you don't have to make changes
across the code in order
to affect a simple change
in the functionality?
There is one big one
which definitely,
especially in the `90s, was
like the big thing in computers.
The big thing.
Well, security actually.
Good.
I don't even have that one down.
Security is excellent.
That's actually been
more in the 2000.
Security has been
far more important
often than performance.
Scalability has been important,
although scalability,
in some sense, is
performance related.
But, yes, scalability is good.
What was the big breakthrough
and why do people use Macintosh
rather than Windows,
those people who
are of that religion?
User-friendliness.
Wow.
If you look at the number of
cycles of computers that went
into user friendliness
in the `90s,
it grew from almost nothing to
where it's now the vast part
of the computation goes
into user friendly.
So, all those things are more
important than performance.
This is a course on performance.
Then you can say OK,
well, why do we bother
and why study algorithms
and performance if it's
at the bottom of the heap?
Almost always
people would rather
have these other things
than performance.
You go off and you
say to somebody,
would I rather have performance
or more user friendliness?
It's almost always more
important than performance.
Why do we care then?
Yeah?
That wasn't user friendly.
Sometimes performance
is correlated with user
friendliness, absolutely.
Nothing is more frustrating than
sitting there waiting, right?
So, that's a good reason.
What are some other reasons why?
Sometimes they have
real time constraints
so they don't actually work
unless they perform adequately.
Yeah?
Hard to get, well,
we don't usually
quantify user friendliness
so I'm not sure,
but I understand
what you're saying.
He said we don't get exponential
performance improvements
in user friendliness.
We often don't get that in
performance either, by the way.
[LAUGHTER] Sometimes
we do, but that's good.
There are several reasons
that I think are important.
Once is that often
performance measures
the line between the
feasible and the infeasible.
We have heard some
of these things.
For example, when there
are real time requirements,
if it's not fast enough
it's simply not functional.
Or, if it uses too much
memory it's simply not
going to work for you.
And, as a consequence,
what you find is algorithms
are on the cutting edge
of entrepreneurship.
If you're talking about
just re implementing stuff
that people did ten
years ago, performance
isn't that important
at some level.
But, if you're talking
about doing stuff
that nobody has done
before, one of the reasons
often that they haven't
done it is because it's too
time consuming.
Things don't scale and so forth.
So, that's one reason, is the
feasible versus infeasible.
Another thing is that
algorithms give you
a language for talking
about program behavior,
and that turns out
to be a language that
has been pervasive
through computer science,
is that the theoretical language
is what gets adopted by all
the practitioners because
it's a clean way of thinking
about things.
A good way I think
about performance,
and the reason it's on
the bottom of the heap,
is sort of like performance is
like money, it's like currency.
You say what good does a
stack of hundred dollar bills
do for you?
Would you rather have food or
water or shelter or whatever?
And you're willing to
pay those hundred dollar
bills, if you have
hundred dollar bills,
for that commodity.
Even though water is far more
important to your living.
Well, similarly,
performance is what you use
to pay for user friendliness.
It's what you pay for security.
And you hear people
say, for example,
that I want greater
functionality,
so people will program
in Java, even though it's
much slower than
C, because they'll
say it costs me maybe
a factor of three
or something in performance
to program in Java.
But Java is worth
it because it's
got all these object oriented
features and so forth,
exception mechanisms and so on.
And so people are willing
to pay a factor of three
in performance.
So, that's why you
want performance
because you can use it to
pay for these other things
that you want.
And that's why, in some sense,
it's on the bottom of the heap,
because it's the universal
thing that you quantify.
Do you want to spend a
factor of two on this
or spend a factor of three
on security, et cetera?
And, in addition, the
lessons generalize
to other resource measures
like communication,
like memory and so forth.
And the last reason we
study algorithm performance
is it's tons of fun.
Speed is always fun, right?
Why do people drive fast
cars, race horses, whatever?
Rockets, et cetera,
why do we do that?
Because speed is fun.
Ski.
Who likes to ski?
I love to ski.
I like going fast on those skis.
It's fun.
Hockey, fast sports, right?
We all like the fast sports.
Not all of us, I mean.
Some people say he's
not talking to me.
OK, let's move on.
That's sort of a little bit of a
notion as to why we study this,
is that it does,
in some sense, form
a common basis for all these
other things we care about.
And so we want to understand
how can we generate money
for ourselves in computation?
We're going to start out
with a very simple problem.
It's one of the
oldest problems that
has been studied in algorithms,
is the problem of sorting.
We're going to actually study
this for several lectures
because sorting contains
many algorithmic techniques.
The sorting problem
is the following.
We have a sequence a 1, a 2
up to a n of numbers as input.
And our output is a
permutation of those numbers.
A permutation is a
rearrangement of the numbers.
Every number appears exactly
once in the rearrangement such
that, I sometimes use a dollar
sign to mean "such that,"
a 1 is less than or
equal to a 2 prime.
Such that they are monotonically
increasing in size.
Take a bunch of numbers,
put them in order.
Here's an algorithm to do it.
It's called insertion sort.
And we will write this algorithm
in what we call pseudocode.
It's sort of a
programming language,
except it's got
English in there often.
And it's just a shorthand for
writing for being precise.
So this sorts A from 1 to n.
And here is the code for it.
This is what we call pseudocode.
And if you don't understand
the pseudocode then
you should ask questions
about any of the notations.
You will start to get
used to it as we go on.
One thing is that
in the pseudocode
we use indentation,
where in most languages
they have some kind of begin
end delimiters like curly braces
or something in Java
or C, for example.
We just use indentation.
The whole idea of
the pseudocode is
to try to get the algorithms
as short as possible
while still understanding
what the individual steps are.
In practice, there
actually have been
languages that use indentation
as a means of showing
the nesting of things.
It's generally a bad idea,
because if things go over one
page to another, for example,
you cannot tell what level
of nesting it is.
Whereas, with explicit braces
it's much easier to tell.
So, there are reasons why this
is a bad notation if you were
doing software engineering.
But it's a good one
for us because it just
keeps things short and makes
fewer things to write down.
So, this is insertion sort.
Let's try to figure out a
little bit what this does.
It basically takes an
array A and at any point
the thing to understand is,
we're setting basically,
we're running the outer
loop from j is 2 to n,
and the inner loop that
starts at j minus 1
and then goes down
until it's zero.
Basically, if we look at
any point in the algorithm,
we essentially are looking
at some element here j.
A of j, the jth element.
And what we do essentially
is we pull a value out
here that we call the key.
And at this point the
important thing to understand,
and we'll talk more about
this in recitation on Friday,
is that there is an invariant
that is being maintained
by this loop each time through.
And the invariant is that this
part of the array is sorted.
And the goal each time through
the loop is to increase,
is to add one to the length
of the things that are sorted.
And the way we do that
is we pull out the key
and we just copy
values up like this.
And keep copying
up until we find
the place where this
key goes, and then we
insert it in that place.
And that's why it's
called insertion sort.
We just sort of move the
things, copy the things up
until we find where it goes,
and then we put it into place.
And now we have it from A
from one to j is sorted,
and now we can
work on j plus one.
Let's give an example of that.
Imagine we are doing
8, 2, 4, 9, 3, 6.
We start out with j equals 2.
And we figure out that we
want to insert it there.
Now we have 2, 8, 4, 9, 3, 6.
Then we look at the four and say
oh, well, that goes over here.
We get 2, 4, 8, 9, 3, 6
after the second iteration
of the outer loop.
Then we look at 9 and
discover immediately it just
goes right there.
Very little work
to do on that step.
So, we have exactly the same
output after that iteration.
Then we look at the
3 and that's going
to be inserted over there.
2, 3, 4, 8, 9, and
that goes in there.
2, 3, 4, 6, 8,
Question?
The array initially
starts at one, yes.
A[1...n], OK?
So, this is the
insertion sort algorithm.
And it's the first algorithm
that we're going to analyze.
And we're going to
pull out some tools
that we have from
our math background
to help to analyze it.
First of all, let's take a look
at the issue of running time.
The running time depends,
of this algorithm
depends on a lot of things.
One thing it depends
on is the input itself.
For example, if the input
is already sorted -- --
then insertion sort has
very little work to do.
Because every time through it's
going to be like this case.
It doesn't have to
shuffle too many guys over
because they're
already in place.
Whereas, in some sense,
what's the worst case
for insertion sort?
If it is reverse
sorted then it's
going to have to
do a lot of work
because it's going to have
to shuffle everything over
on each step of the outer loop.
In addition to the actual
input it depends, of course,
on the input size.
Here, for example,
we did six elements.
It's going to take longer if
we, for example, do six times
ten to the ninth elements.
If we were sorting
a lot more stuff,
it's going to take
us a lot longer.
Typically, the way
we handle that is we
are going to parameterize
things in the input size.
We are going to talk
about time as a function
of the size of
things that we are
sorting so we can look at
what is the behavior of that.
And the last thing I want
to say about running time
is generally we want upper
bonds on the running time.
We want to know that the time is
no more than a certain amount.
And the reason is because
that represents a guarantee
to the user.
If I say it's not going to
run, for example, if I tell
you here's a program
and it won't run
more than three
seconds, that gives you
real information about how
you could use it, for example,
in a real time setting.
Whereas, if I said
here's a program
and it goes at
least three seconds,
you don't know if it's
going to go for three years.
It doesn't give you
that much guarantee
if you are a user of it.
Generally we want upper
bonds because it represents
a guarantee to the user.
There are different kinds
of analyses that people do.
The one we're mostly
going to focus on
is what's called
worst case analysis.
And this is what we do
usually where we define T of n
to be the maximum time
on any input of size n.
So, it's the maximum input,
the maximum it could possibly
cost us on an input of size n.
What that does is, if
you look at the fact
that sometimes the
inputs are better
and sometimes
they're worse, we're
looking at the
worst case of those
because that's the
way we're going
to be able to make a guarantee.
It always does something
rather than just sometimes
does something.
So, we're looking
at the maximum.
Notice that if I didn't have
maximum then T(n) in some sense
is a relation, not a
function, because the time
on an input of size n depends
on which input of size n.
I could have many
different times,
but by putting
the maximum at it,
it turns that relation
into a function
because there's only one
maximum time that it will take.
Sometimes we will talk
about average case.
Sometimes we will do this.
Here T of n is then the expected
time over all inputs of size n.
It's the expected time.
Now, if I talk about
expected time, what else do
I need to say here?
What does that
mean, expected time?
I'm sorry.
Raise your hand.
Expected inputs.
What does that mean,
expected inputs?
I need more math.
What do I need by
expected time here, math?
You have to take the
time of every input
and then average them, OK.
That's kind of what we
mean by expected time.
Good.
Not quite.
I mean, what you say
is completely correct,
except is not quite enough.
Yeah?
It's the time of every
input times the probability
that it will be that input.
It's a way of taking a weighted
average, exactly right.
How do I know what the
probability of every input is?
probability a particular input
occurs is in a given situation?
I don't.
I have to make an assumption.
What's that assumption called?
What kind of assumption
do I have to meet?
I need an assumption -- -- of
the statistical distribution
of inputs.
Otherwise, expected time
doesn't mean anything
because I don't know what the
probability of something is.
In order to do probability,
you need some assumptions
and you've got to state
those assumptions clearly.
One of the most
common assumptions
is that all inputs
are equally likely.
That's called the
uniform distribution.
Every input of size n is equally
likely, that kind of thing.
But there are other ways that
you could make that assumption,
and they may not all be true.
This is much more
complicated, as you can see.
Fortunately, all of you have a
strong probability background.
And so we will not have
any trouble addressing
these probabilistic
issues of dealing
with expectations and such.
If you don't, time
to go and say gee,
maybe I should take
that Probability class
that is a prerequisite
for this class.
The last one I am going to
mention is best case analysis.
And this I claim is bogus.
Bogus.
No good.
Why is best-case analysis bogus?
Yeah?
The best case probably
doesn't ever happen.
Actually, it's interesting
because for the sorting
problem, the most common
things that get sorted
are things that are already
sorted interestingly,
or at least almost sorted.
For example, one of the most
common things that are sorted
is check numbers by banks.
They tend to come in, in
the same order that they
are written.
They're sorting things that
are almost always sorted.
I mean, it's good.
When upper bond,
not lower bound?
Yeah, you want to
make a guarantee.
And so why is this
not a guarantee?
You're onto something there, but
we need a little more precision
here.
How can I cheat?
Yeah?
Yeah, you can cheat.
You cheat.
You take any slow
algorithm that you want
and just check for
some particular input,
and if it's that input, then you
say immediately yeah, OK, here
is the answer.
And then it's got
a good best case.
But I didn't tell you anything
about the vast majority
of what is going on.
So, you can cheat
with a slow algorithm
that works fast on some input.
It doesn't really
do much for you
so we normally don't
worry about that.
Let's see.
What is insertion
sorts worst case time?
Now we get into some
sort of funny issues.
First of all, it sort of
depends on the computer
you're running on.
Whose computer, right?
Is it a big supercomputer
or is it your wristwatch?
They have different
computational abilities.
And when we compare
algorithms, we
compare them typically
for relative speed.
This is if you compared two
algorithms on the same machine.
You could argue, well,
it doesn't really
matter what the machine
is because I will just
look at their relative speed.
But, of course, I may also be
interested in absolute speed.
Is one algorithm
actually better no matter
what machine it's run on?
And so this kind of
gets sort of confusing
as to how I can talk
about the worst case
time of an algorithm
of a piece of software
when I am not talking
about the hardware because,
clearly, if I had run
on a faster machine,
my algorithms are
going to go faster.
So, this is where you get
the big idea of algorithms.
Which is why algorithm
is such a huge field,
why it spawns companies
like Google, like Akamai,
like Amazon.
Why algorithmic analysis,
throughout the history
of computing, has been
such a huge success,
is our ability to
master and to be
able to take what is
apparently a really
messy, complicated situation
and reduce it to being
able to do some mathematics.
And that idea is called
asymptotic analysis.
And the basic idea of
asymptotic analysis is to ignore
machine-dependent
constants -- --
and, instead of the
actual running time,
look at the growth
of the running time.
So, we don't look at
the actual running time.
We look at the growth.
Let's see what we mean by that.
This is a huge idea.
It's not a hard
idea, otherwise I
wouldn't be able to teach
it in the first lecture,
but it's a huge idea.
We are going to spend
a couple of lectures
understanding the
implications of that
and will basically be doing
it throughout the term.
And if you go on to be
practicing engineers,
you will be doing
it all the time.
In order to do that,
we adopt some notations
that are going to help us.
In particular, we will
adopt asymptotic notation.
Most of you have seen some
kind of asymptotic notation.
Maybe a few of you
haven't, but mostly you
should have seen a little bit.
The one we're going to
be using in this class
predominantly is theta notation.
And theta notation is
pretty easy notation
to master because all you
do is, from a formula,
just drop low order terms
and ignore leading constants.
For example, if I have a formula
like 3n^3 = 90n^2 - 5n + 6046,
I say, well, what low
order terms do I drop?
Well, n^3 is a
bigger term n^2 than.
I am going to drop all these
terms and ignore the leading
constant, so I say
that's Theta(n^3).
That's pretty easy.
So, that's theta notation.
Now, this is an engineering way
of manipulating theta notation.
There is actually a
mathematical definition
for this, which we
are going to talk
about next time, which
is a definition in terms
of sets of functions.
And, you are going
to be responsible,
this is both a math and a
computer science engineering
class.
Throughout the
course you are going
to be responsible both
for mathematical rigor
as if it were a math
course and engineering
commonsense because it's
an engineering course.
We are going to be doing both.
This is the engineering way
of understanding what you do,
so you're responsible for being
able to do these manipulations.
You're also going to be
responsible for understanding
the mathematical
definition of theta notion
and of its related O
notation and omega notation.
If I take a look as n
approached infinity,
a Theta(n^2) algorithm
always beats, eventually,
a Theta(n^3) algorithm.
As n gets bigger, it doesn't
matter what these other terms
were if I were describing
the absolute precise behavior
in terms of a formula.
If I had a Theta(n^2) algorithm,
it would always be faster
for sufficiently large n
than a Theta(n^3) algorithm.
It wouldn't matter what
those low order terms were.
the leading constant was.
This one will always be faster.
Even if you ran the Theta(n^2)
algorithm on a slow computer
and the Theta(n^3) algorithm
on a fast computer.
The great thing about
asymptotic notation
is it satisfies
our issue of being
able to compare both
relative and absolute speed,
because we are able
to do this no matter
what the computer platform.
On different platforms we may
get different constants here,
machine dependent constants
for the actual running time,
but if I look at the growth
as the size of the input
gets larger, the asymptotics
generally won't change.
For example, I will just
draw that as a picture.
If I have n on this axis
and T(n) on this axis.
This may be, for example, a
Theta(n^3) algorithm and this
may be a Theta(n^2) algorithm.
There is always going to be some
point n o where for everything
larger the Theta(n^2) algorithm
is going to be cheaper than
the Theta(n^3) algorithm not
matter how much advantage you
give it at the beginning
in terms of the speed
of the computer
you are running on.
Now, from an engineering
point of view,
there are some issues we have to
deal with because sometimes it
could be that that n o is so
large that the computers aren't
big enough to run the problem.
That's why we, nevertheless,
are interested in some
of the slower algorithms,
because some of the slower
algorithms, even though they may
not asymptotically be slower,
I mean asymptotically
they will be slower.
They may still be faster on
reasonable sizes of things.
And so we have to both balance
our mathematical understanding
with our engineering
commonsense in order
to do good programming.
So, just having done
analysis of algorithms
doesn't automatically make
you a good programmer.
You also need to learn
how to program and use
these tools in
practice to understand
when they are relevant and
when they are not relevant.
There is a saying.
If you want to be
a good program,
you just program ever
day for two years,
you will be an
excellent programmer.
If you want to be a
world class programmer,
you can program every
day for ten years,
or you can program
every day for two years
and take an algorithms class.
Let's get back to
what we were doing,
which is analyzing
insertion sort.
We are going to look
at the worse case.
Which, as we mentioned before,
is when the input is reverse
sorted.
The biggest element comes
first and the smallest last
because now every time you
do the insertion you've
got to shuffle everything over.
You can write down
the running time
by looking at the
nesting of loops.
What we do is we sum up.
What we assume is
that every operation,
every elemental operation
is going to take
some constant amount of time.
But we don't have
to worry about what
that constant is because
we're going to be
doing asymptotic analysis.
As I say, the
beautify of the method
is that it causes
all these things that
are real distinctions
to sort of vanish.
We sort of look at
them from 30,000 feet
rather than from three
millimeters or something.
Each of these operations
is going to sort of
be a basic operation.
One way to think about this, in
terms of counting operations,
is counting memory references.
How many times do you
actually access some variable?
That's another way of sort
of thinking about this model.
When we do that, well, we're
going to go through this loop,
j is going from 2
to n, and then we're
going to add up the work
that we do within the loop.
We can sort of write that
in math as summation of j
equals 2 to n.
And then what is the work
that is going on in this loop?
Well, the work that is
going on in this loop
varies, but in the worst case
how many operations are going
on here for each value of j?
For a given value of j, how
much work goes on in this loop?
Can somebody tell me?
Asymptotically.
It's j times some
constant, so it's theta j.
So, there is theta
j work going on here
because this loop starts
out with i being j minus 1,
and then it's doing just
a constant amount of stuff
for each step of the value
of i, and i is running
from j minus one down to zero.
So, we can say that is theta
j work that is going on.
Do people follow that?
OK.
And now we have a
formula we can evaluate.
What is the evaluation?
If I want to simplify this
formula, what is that equal to?
Sorry.
In the back there.
Yeah.
OK.
That's just Theta(n^2), good.
Because when you're saying is
the sum of consecutive numbers,
you mean what?
What's the mathematic
term we have
for that so we can communicate?
You've got to know these
things so you can communicate.
It's called what
type of sequence?
It's actually a
series, but that's OK.
What type of series
is this called?
Arithmetic series, good.
Wow, we've got some sharp
people who can communicate.
This is an arithmetic series.
You're basically summing 1 + 2 +
3 + 4, some constants in there,
but basically it's 1 + 2
+ 3 + 4 + 5 + 6 up to n.
That's Theta(n^2).
If you don't know this math,
there is a chapter in the book,
or you could have
taken the prerequisite.
Arithmetic series.
People have this
vague recollection.
Oh, yeah.
Good.
Now, you have to learn
these manipulations.
We will talk about
a bit next time,
but you have to learn
your theta manipulations
for what works with theta.
And you have to be very
careful because theta
is a weak notation.
A strong notation is something
like Leibniz notation
from calculus where
the chain rule is just
canceling two things.
It's just fabulous that you
can cancel in the chain rule.
And Leibniz notation just
expresses that so directly you
can manipulate.
Theta notation is not like that.
If you think it is like
that you are in trouble.
You really have to think
of what is going on
under the theta notation.
And it is more of a
descriptive notation
than it is a
manipulative notation.
There are manipulations
you can do with it,
but unless you
understand what is really
going on under the theta
notation you will find yourself
in trouble.
And next time we will
talk a little bit more
about theta notation.
Is insertion sort fast?
Well, it turns out for small
n it is moderately fast.
But it is not at
all for large n.
So, I am going to give you
an algorithm that is faster.
It's called merge sort.
I wonder if I should
leave insertion sort up.
Why not.
I am going to write
on this later,
so if you are taking notes,
leave some space on the left.
Here is merge sort of an
array A from 1 up to n.
And it is basically three steps.
If n equals 1 we are done.
Sorting one element,
it is already sorted.
All right.
Recursive algorithm.
Otherwise, what we do is we
recursively sort A from 1
up to the ceiling of n over 2.
And the array A of the ceiling
of n over 2 plus one up to n.
So, we sort two
halves of the input.
And then, three, we take those
two lists that we have done
and we merge them.
And, to do that, we
use a merge subroutine
which I will show you.
The key subroutine here is
merge, and it works like this.
I have two lists.
Let's say one of them is 20.
I am doing this
in reverse order.
I have sorted this like this.
And then I sort another one.
I don't know why I do it
this order, but anyway.
Here is my other list.
I have my two lists
that I have sorted.
So, this is AA[1] to AA[|n/2|] and
AA[|n/2|+1] to AA[n] for the way
it will be called
in this program.
And now to merge these
two, what I want to do
is produce a sorted list
out of both of them.
What I do is first observe
where is the smallest
element of any two lists
that are already sorted?
It's in one of two places,
the head of the first list
or the head of the second list.
I look at those two elements
and say which one is smaller?
This one is smaller.
Then what I do is output
into my output array
the smaller of the two.
And I cross it off.
And now where is the
next smallest element?
And the answer is it's going to
be the head of one of these two
lists.
Then I cross out this
guy and put him here
and circle this one.
Now I look at these two guys.
This one is smaller so I output
that and circle that one.
Now I look at these
two guys, output 9.
So, every step here is some
fixed number of operations
that is independent of the size
of the arrays at each step.
Each individual step is just
me looking at two elements
and picking out the smallest
and advancing some pointers
into the array so
that I know where
the current head
of that list is.
And so, therefore, the time is
order n on n total elements.
The time to actually go through
this and merge two lists
is order n.
We sometimes call this linear
time because it's not quadratic
or whatever.
It is proportional to n,
proportional to the input size.
It's linear time.
I go through and just do
this simple operation,
just working up these
lists, and in the end
I have done essentially
n operations,
order n operations each of
which cost constant time.
That's a total of order n time.
Everybody with me?
OK.
So, this is a recursive program.
We can actually now
write what is called
a recurrence for this program.
The way we do that is
say let's let the time
to sort n elements to be T(n).
Then how long does it
take to do step one?
That's just constant time.
We just check to see if n is
1, and if it is we return.
That's independent of the size
of anything that we are doing.
It just takes a certain
number of machine instructions
on whatever machine and we
say it is constant time.
We call that theta one.
This is actually a little bit
of an abuse if you get into it.
And the reason is because
typically in order to say it
you need to say what
it is growing with.
Nevertheless, we use this
as an abuse of the notation
just to mean it is a constant.
So, that's an abuse
just so people know.
But it simplifies things if
I can just write theta one.
And it basically
means the same thing.
Now we recursively
sort these two things.
How can I describe that?
The time to do this, I
can describe recursively
as T of ceiling
of n over 2 plus T
of n minus ceiling of n over 2.
That is actually kind of messy,
so what we will do is just be
sloppy and write 2T(n/2).
So, this is just
us being sloppy.
And we will see on
Friday in recitation
that it is OK to be sloppy.
That's the great thing
about algorithms.
As long as you are
rigorous and precise,
you can be as
sloppy as you want.
[LAUGHTER] This is sloppy
because I didn't worry
about what was going
on, because it turns out
it doesn't make any difference.
And we are going to actually
see that that is the case.
And, finally, I have to merge
the two sorted lists which
have a total of n elements.
And we just analyze that
using the merge subroutine.
And that takes us
to theta n time.
That allows us now to write a
recurrence for the performance
of merge sort.
Which is to say that T
of n is equal to theta 1
if n equals 1 and 2T of
n over 2 plus theta of n
if n is bigger than 1.
Because either I
am doing step one
or I am doing all steps
one, two and three.
Here I am doing step one
and I return and I am done.
Or else I am doing step
one, I don't return,
and then I also do
steps two and three.
So, I add those together.
I could say theta n plus theta
1, but theta n plus theta 1
is just theta n because
theta 1 is a lower order
term than theta n and
I can throw it away.
It is either theta 1 or it is
2T of n over 2 plus theta n.
Now, typically we
won't be writing this.
Usually we omit this.
If it makes no difference to
the solution of the recurrence,
we will usually omit
constant base cases.
In algorithms, it's not true
generally in mathematics,
but in algorithms if you
are running something
on a constant size input it
takes constant time always.
So, we don't worry about
what this value is.
And it turns out it
has no real impact
on the asymptotic solution
of the recurrence.
How do we solve a
recurrence like this?
I now have T of n expressed
in terms of T of n over 2.
That's in the book and
it is also in Lecture 2.
We are going to do
Lecture 2 to solve that,
but in the meantime
what I am going
to do is give you a visual
way of understanding what
this costs, which is
one of the techniques
we will elaborate on next time.
It is called a recursion
tree technique.
And I will use it for the
actual recurrence that is almost
the same 2T(n/2), but I am
going to actually explicitly,
because I want you to
see where it occurs,
plus some constant times n where
c is a constant greater than
zero.
So, we are going to look at
this recurrence with a base
case of order one.
I am just making the
constant in here,
the upper bound
on the constant be
explicit rather than implicit.
And the way you do a recursion
tree is the following.
You start out by writing
down the left hand
side of the recurrence.
And then what you do is you
say well, that is equal to,
and now let's
write it as a tree.
I do c of n work plus now I
am going to have to do work
on each of my two children.
T of n over 2 and T of n over
If I sum up what is in here,
I get this because that is
what the recurrence says,
T(n)=2T(n/2)+cn.
I have 2T(n/2)+cn.
Then I do it again.
I have cn here.
I now have here cn/2.
And here is cn/2.
And each of these
now has a T(n/4).
And these each have a T(n/4).
And this has a T(n/4).
And I keep doing that, the
dangerous dot, dot, dots.
And, if I keep doing that, I end
up with it looking like this.
And I keep going down
until I get to a leaf.
And a leaf, I have
essentially a T(1).
That is T(1).
And so the first question
I ask here is, what
is the height of this tree?
Yeah.
It's log n.
It's actually very
close to exactly log n
because I am starting
out at the top with n
and then I go to n/2 and n/4
and all the way down until I
get to The number of halvings
of n until I get to 1 is
log n so the height
here is log n.
It's OK if it is
constant times log n.
It doesn't matter.
How many leaves are in
this tree, by the way?
How many leaves
does this tree have?
Yeah.
The number of
leaves, once again,
is actually pretty close.
It's actually n.
If you took it all the way down.
Let's make some simplifying
assumption. n is
a perfect power of 2, so it
is an integer power of 2.
Then this is exactly log
n to get down to T(1).
And then there are
exactly n leaves,
because the number
of leaves here,
the number of nodes at
this level is 1, 2, 4, 8.
And if I go down
height h, I have
2 to the h leaves, 2 to
the log n, that is just n.
We are doing math here, right?
Now let's figure
out how much work,
if I look at adding up
everything in this tree
I am going to get T(n),
so let's add that up.
Well, let's add it
up level by level.
How much do we have
in the first level?
Just cn.
If I add up the second
level, how much do I have?
cn.
How about if I add up
the third level? cn.
How about if I add
up all the leaves?
Theta n.
It is not necessarily cn
because the boundary case
may have a different constant.
It is actually theta n,
but cn all the way here.
If I add up the
total amount, that
is equal to cn times
log n, because that's
the height, that is how many
cn's I have here, plus theta n.
And this is a higher order term
than this, so this goes away,
get rid of the constants, that
is equal to theta(n lg n).
And theta(n lg n) is
asymptotically faster than
theta(n^2).
So, merge sort, on a
large enough input size,
is going to beat insertion sort.
Merge sort is going to
be a faster algorithm.
Sorry, you guys,
I didn't realize
you couldn't see over there.
You should speak up
if you cannot see.
So, this is a faster algorithm
because theta(n lg n) grows
more slowly than theta(n^2).
And merge sort asymptotically
beats insertion sort.
Even if you ran insertion
sort on a supercomputer,
somebody running on a PC with
merge sort for sufficient large
input will clobber them because
actually n^2 is way bigger than
n log n once you get
the n's to be large.
And, in practice, merge sort
tends to win here for n bigger
than, say, 30 or so.
If you have a very small
input like 30 elements,
insertion sort is a
perfectly decent sort to use.
But merge sort is going to be
a lot faster even for something
that is only a few
dozen elements.
It is going to actually
be a faster algorithm.
That's sort of the lessons, OK?
Remember that to get your
recitation assignments
and attend recitation on Friday.
Because we are going to be going
through a bunch of the things
that I have left
on the table here.
And see you next Monday.